what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to a clip by coach greg
adams saying polly relationships are the
future before i start
do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and bring the notification bell
that way you're going to be notified of
my daily
videos okay so this is going to be
interesting because
um anyone that's watched my channel for
a while knows that i grew up with like
two parents in my house and like they
were mayor they've been married for like
30 years so it'll be interesting
to see like a different perspective
remember i talked about oh my gosh
this is kind of loud this on a live
stream this is going to be a long live
stream by the way
so don't complain here's what's next i
talked about this
poly relationships polyamory polygeny
polyamory is typically when women have
multiple partners
and polygeny polygeny is when men have
multiple partners
polygamy is the active or
uh i mean you're starting to see this
now even on like tick-tock and stuff i
see these like
throughputs and like open relationships
all the time
and having multiple wives
now some people are going what is he
talking about this is not even possible
but take this into consideration we have
literally seen in the past
three decades the evolution
and acceptance of many types of what
they used to call
alternative relationships swinging
single mothers having value on the
marketplace
gay homosexual relationships bisexual
relationships transgender relationships
where a person will trans
into something else and then date
somebody of the opposite gender
i mean it creates confusion today
it's more than acceptable to have any of
these relationships 30 years ago you
would be an outsider
right 30 years ago you might be even
ostracized
so if you think about it in the last 30
years we've seen the acceptance of a lot
of different
type of relationships even now you got
multiple letters every week they add a
letter l b
t g k p u s i don't know what they're
talking about
yeah i mean everything he's saying right
now is true relationships definitely the
last 30 years have like
evolved where you see it's like pretty
normal you see a lot of things that
aren't
that are pretty normal like more normal
today than it would be 30 years ago so
like what are you saying is right
now the modern day monogamous
relationships in couples
that whole dynamic is in trouble
that whole dynamic is in trouble now
people will naturally want it because
many people are conditioned
many people will say they're in
monogamous relationships when they're
not
even today people who are in affairs are
literally not in monogamous
relationships
many people who are married at about 50
on both male
and female wife and husband are having
affairs
so the idea that we are really is it
that high
50 i wonder
how the 50 like
which part like is it like the same
50 or having affairs or is it like i was
just curious how
that like evens out and when they say
affairs
is it like a long-term short-term um
yeah i'm i'm interested to see what he
says really practicing monogamy
is a myth we're not practicing monogamy
more than likely most people aren't
although they say they are
but do you feel like that's different i
have a question for the audience do you
guys feel like that
has changed over time or do you think
social media and like surveying
and the ability to obtain information
easier has like brought more that stuff
to life
so question and the comments because i
would probably guess
that social media probably didn't help
because i'm sure that makes stuff easier
um but i would guess that the numbers
might have been similar before but i
actually don't know so let me know in
the comments
but monogamous relationships today
they're not as necessary as they were
in the past see family is no longer
celebrated it is actually you can
actually get demonized for wanting to be
a traditional family
and it's no longer a priority families
are no longer a priority
like raising your kids is no longer a
priority you can go out here
be a slower you could be out here being
a male [ __ ]
go out there have kids have them live
over here
date over here fornicate over the kids
are no longer a priority
well i wouldn't even necessarily say
that i mean
he there's some truth into what he's
saying but i would say that
if i looked at like society as a whole
before women didn't really have a choice
because
they didn't have birth control so the
introduction of birth control into
society
gave women like the option to
focus on a career instead of kids where
before like that
i mean you could you could it would just
be a lot more difficult
so a lot of women when giving that
choice
would rather like chase their career
um the issue that i've seen anyway is
after like a certain age
they tend to regret that decision from
from what i've seen
but you know let me know in the comments
if you think that's false
today feelings are more important even
if i change my feeling the next day
what i feel in that moment is just is
more important
as what i feel like tomorrow there's no
accountability to others
there's no accountability for actions
you can mess up your entire life
make poor decisions more poor choices
and then blame somebody else
later this is the society we live in
so marriages as a result they're
struggling
and there's no more communities you
don't even know your neighbor you live
in a nice community a gated community
you still don't know your neighbors
there used to be a time where the
community centered around
the church and everybody would go to the
church in their community and run back
to their houses
and you would play at the park and play
in a league that's all gone now
most of you cheating au coaches don't
even have your players in the same
community but
i don't see i would disagree i would say
communities more of
evolved into where people have like
online communities and they have
communities
in different areas and like more
traditionally and this kind of goes back
to like
choice like when people have the ability
to choose different communities they
might not necessarily choose the ones
that they like live around anyway shame
is gone remember you can shame a person
for having 100
bodies on them 100 person body count by
the age of 24
you can't do that now she can claim to
be valuable
and she can shame others for saying that
she's a
you know a used up material and
hypergamy
is off the charts and that is even
before the lockdown
this is even before the lockdown
now you add the lockdown issues in there
you add the impact of the economy
and i believe that polygamy
i'm sorry polygyny and polyamory are
going to be
the wave of the future now
so my question would be like at what
rate
i'm sure i'm sure you'll see an increase
in that but
is that going to be the majority um
i would guess no but i'm gonna listen
more
i want you to get this out of your mind
when i talk about polyamory
and polygeny get this out of your mind
the old
polygamous family where there's women
dressed in
all you know the modest uniforms living
together
all right walking around as sister wives
i want you to erase that from your
memory because that's what people think
that i'm talking about here
you think that i'm talking about there's
going to be one household sister wives
or sister husbands or
bro husbands whatever you want to call
it and everybody's going to be seeing it
out in public
here's an example here let's blow this
up so you can see this oh i know
i saw this like documentary it was so
weird
oh it was so weird
this is an example of a modern day
polygamy
sorry polyamory polyamorous relationship
they do not look happy oh my goodness
they do not look happy
and but the thing is like i'm sure we'll
see an increase in this but is this
gonna be the majority of the population
like do you really think you're gonna be
seeing couples like that everywhere
i'd like do you do any of you guys
personally know
any throuples or whatever you would call
this
i don't but i'm gonna listen it's the
modern day
polyamorous relationship and you have to
remember when you see things online that
doesn't necessarily reflect like reality
like of course i'll see like open
relationships and drupals
online but like do you know any
personally i don't
um and a lot of times like obviously
that's going to get the most attention
a busted pillsbury biscuit can
with four beta males okay
four beta males and this woman is
pregnant
and she's pregnant by one of these men
who she didn't know she assumed it was
one man's baby
but it was actually another man's baby
this is the example of a potential
polyamorous
relationship now
these relationships are going on now
these are what's gonna happen
all right this is what i'm talking about
believe it or not we are unofficially
practicing
poly relationships right now okay it's
just not on paper yet at some point it
may be on paper
but right now we're already doing it now
listen anybody
that's a young girl you're on seeking
arrangements you're on only fans
you're being paid and sponsored by other
men and you got a little boyfriend back
at college
and i also want to say that again you
see this
all the time online i'm like especially
in the manners for all the girls that
come on these shows
but like in all honesty i don't
personally know a single girl that does
only fans
like actually and i'm not saying like
girls don't do that they definitely do
but i don't think it's as prevalent as a
lot of these like
people in this community think it is
you got a little boyfriend back in your
neighborhood waiting for you to come
back from college
you're living in a poly relationship
you have multiple men and you're using
multiple men for different reasons
anyone who is advertised advertising
themselves on social media
instagram snapchat dating apps and
you're in a relationship
with the traditional relationship you're
in a poly relationship these are going
to be the modern
poly relationships these will be the
norm it will be accepted
anyone who is knowingly sleeping with
another person
who is married you having an affair with
the married man
that will be fair game people will look
the other way they will just go okay
polly relationships see if i had to
guess i would think the opposite
um because of social media it's becoming
harder and harder to hide that stuff
um so one option is that people might
just end up
saying this is how it is and start like
living the poly lifestyle
but it'd be interesting to see if as it
becomes harder and harder to cover up
people would maybe choose different
routes i mean even bill gates didn't
hide his mistress and that man has more
money than any and same with jeff's
jeff bezos like they both have so much
money
and even like with all the money they
have they didn't hide that
any woman that is dating a beta male and
they're getting their back blown out by
alpha male is a poly relationship
they're getting multiple things from
multiple different men
a single parent more or less engaging
in relationships meaning there's another
father in the picture he's in the family
dynamics
and you're dating that's a poly
relationship vice versa if it's a man
same thing you're in a poly relationship
a husband who has a sugar baby and a
wife at home
is a poly relationship but again how
many people do you actually
know like i don't know a single sugar
baby
i see them all the time online i just
genuinely don't
i would actually i do know one girl but
it actually did not work out
in her favor she ended up getting robbed
so i don't know like any true sugar
babies
sometimes the wife even is aware that
the husband is philandering and she's
even getting her back blown out by her
personal trainer
these are poly relationships and here's
the deal
these poly relationships will be the
norm people will say and
they're gonna look the other way
they're just gonna be like that's just
what it is before we would fight it and
shame people and give them the scarlet
letter and divorce them and break up
i don't know derek jenks people
definitely shamed him
i had never heard of him before his
affair
but people definitely shamed him now
people will say i'll be one or the other
it's fine
i'll be this part of the poly i'll be
that part of the pawn
now the future poly relationships will
be more transactional than they will be
communal
so before like you said the social wives
right they're going to be more
transactional i'm this part of the
relationship so therefore i have to stay
he's paying me or i'm the wife and he
supports me
so i have to stay even though i know he
has a sugar baby or
i'm a single mom and the dad pays me
child support but i do
get dates from this guy or this guy's a
deadbeat but i get child support
from this good man and therefore i
support this man
as a means to make it through you see
you also have to realize that like
life people live longer
so if you had a 20-year marriage like
before that would be half your life if
you live to be
like because i think i don't want to
miss speak but like let's say the
average life span was like
50 you have a 25-year marriage that's
half your life you could have a 25-year
marriage
you could have two 25-year marriages
and live to be like 75.
isn't that nuts when you think about it
so obviously there's gonna be more
people with like entangled relationships
because they've had more time to do it
what i'm saying
there's going to be a lot of those
relationships and it's going to be
normal the needs
are going to be fulfilled by multiple
people there's going to be a financial
person there's going to be an emotional
person there's going to be a sexual
person
and it will be normal more more women
will have private
politicist relationships and it will be
similar
to how women conducted their sexual
lives
today you won't see it but you know
they're doing it you're going to go on a
date you're going to know she's married
you're going to know she has a sugar
daddy you're going to know she's on
instagram
you're going to know she's going be on
only fans you're gonna know it
you're gonna know other men are
supporting her and you're still going to
date her
and you're still going to consider
marrying her you're just going to say
it is what it is now
you're probably not going to see poly
relationships in the open
you're just going to know what's going
to be done if you do see poly
relationships
you're more likely to see a polyamorous
relationship you'll more likely see
this in the open then you will see
a man with multiple women
you'll probably see a woman with
multiple men out
in the normal in the wild then you will
see
men with multiple women and here's the
reason why
the woman with multiple men will be
praised as heroic
stunning and brave i don't know i
cringed when i saw that video i would
not have called her
brave the man in the open with multiple
women he will probably be shunned
they're going to say why are you doing
this to yourself captain saber holes are
going to come from
everywhere but at the same time whenever
there's like
one disagreement the other like the man
of sphere comes and like has their take
on it or the
conservatives the liberal like each
and every group has their take on a
situation
it's not like one group dominates the
internet
now the only exception to this the only
exception to this
is if the man is so-called higher value
and he has multiple attractive women
in this case the behavior will be
excused as well he has
money or he's uh attractive right
have we seen an example of this let me
show you
let me think yes we have oh my god i
forgot about hugh hefner
you've seen an example of this see if i
did what hugh hefner did
i would be an a-hole now hugh hefner
does it
at age 80 85 and he has 20 and 30 year
old
girlfriends everybody just says well
it is what it is
see these type of poly relationships
they've already been implanted in front
of you
to get you ready for the anytime the
media does this
they do it for a reason and they the
reason i don't understand what he says
the media does this like the media
is just p like it's not like one person
it's like hundreds of thousands of
people anyone can be the media
to get you to accept it in real life at
some point
so if the conditions worsen financially
we're gonna hear and see
more of what reminds you of this
biblical passage
isaiah 4 1 and in that day seven women
shall take hold
of one man saying we will eat of our
own bread and wear our own apparel
only let us be called by thy name to
take away
our shame guys
this is the future coming up and it will
happen if the economics continue
to go this way and yes you have there
was a huge pimp
okay that was an interesting clip i
would probably disagree i bet we'll see
more of that stuff in the media but like
your average person living in like the
suburbs
like your average joe i don't think
you're really gonna see polyamory like
sweep the nation but
who knows let me know in the comments if
you guys agree or you disagree and do
not forget
to subscribe to the channel and ring the
notification
bell i'll talk to you guys next time